nfts are here and they're quite
polarizing a lot of people wonder what's
the value well today we find out i'm
joined by my buddy leon lush yes sir
who's a commentator who has gotten very
interested in nfts like myself and today
i want to challenge us challenge you
leon in a battle of what nfts are truly
worth do they have inherent value so
i've had a third party collect some nfts
of all all values sizes shapes and today
we're going to guess the price and
winner gets the very distinguished title
of king of crypto now i know oh that is
distinguished that's important for me
yeah i i know myself included i i i take
this job very seriously and i'd hate to
hand it over to someone like yourself
um with all respect and love of course
so let's get started this is guess the
price of the nft let's go i am pumped
you excited yeah dude i'm excited listen
there's nothing i like more than
speculating and right now we're sw
normally when i speculate i lose a bunch
of money but right now i'm not going to
lose anything except maybe the kip the
crypto king title so i'm excited right
right right all right let's get this
started round one this is a guess the
price of the nfc okay i guess it's
multiple choices i didn't set this up
blue eyes white okay part of the rare
pepe uh crew these are early on chain uh
nfts
oh
you know your stuff oh my god
so i don't know how rare so there's so
many different ones and a lot of them
come in like different uh issuance
amounts so i'm gonna i want to take a
stab i want to say five eth so what is
what is that in price what does that
give you okay
right right now five eighth about 20k
all right i'm going 40k okay i'm just
stab in the dark i have no idea
oh okay oh multiple choice now that's
right so
all right so
did you say 40k one of your answers i'm
locked in i'm locked in so you're locked
in at 40. so i'm gonna i'm gonna
probably guess a now that i'm seeing
these answers so you're bma i think
it's a hundred thousand dollars all
right
of course that makes sense yeah that
that totally makes sense right all right
in my defense it says at the time so now
that we're in a bit of an nft bear
market maybe it's closer to my price or
your price but no yeah that's probably
one of the rare i guess uh pepes okay
yep 998 crypto punk white hair is a
relatively rare trait i believe i'm
gonna look at the multiple choice i know
the floor at the time he grabbed these
i love that 502 is a choice
oh
man that's not the answer nope
nope uh for the white one i think the
floor was probably like 240. i'm gonna
say c half a million dollars for this
that's i i know for a fact that it's c
but
you know i have insider knowledge on
this this is actually not a real trade
this was a wash trade uh this wasn't
this wasn't a real trade the guy
half a million dollars that was 533 half
a billion dollars yeah half a billion
dollars that's a wash tray i remember
this on twitter as well yeah he flash
traded himself as like a meme to either
drive up the price or just to be funny
about it all right i think okay yeah we
both get that so we're one to one right
now yeah let's get to this next one la
cunar a shallow depression now this one
i feel like i am not familiar with it oh
it's a video too nice
[Music]
now we're getting places it's very
ominous
that's it that's it okay okay so i'm
gonna go ahead and uh say what i think
this is worth the closest thing to what
i think this is worth which is
sixteen hundred dollars i think it's
worth about a dollar to be honest but um
yes i i think i'm going with a myself
yep
i'm unfamiliar i think this one he's
trying to get us on yeah easy yeah
all right hey is that a we're two for
three right now is that a testament to
like maybe not all the nfts are the most
expensive
because sometimes you see these things
like there are some like some of the x
copy stuff some of the art block stuff
that is relatively interesting from an
art perspective still
feels super overvalued occasionally when
you see him selling for like three four
hundred thousand dollars you can
understand from like an art speculation
that just looked like a six-year-old
figured out how to use windows movie
maker well yeah but then you have the
eth rock but okay so then there's the
other side the other extreme which is
the more stupid it is the more expensive
it is yeah so there's that too
all right we're round two
we're through round one two out of three
both of us so round two which still
there will be no nft sold for the most
amount so this is going to be a
comparison thing oh this is spider-man
okay good stuff harry good stuff
lopez likes to stick his long nose into
the other pros business
i uh i'm gonna go with a i'd have no
idea but i just think the a is the more
relevant i was going with a2 yeah i'm
spider-man you know what i'll go b you
know why not because i really believe in
it but because it sounds like it's part
of a crypto collection
and those always do
yes well son of a [ __ ]
yeah that's right that's right dude just
put it in series of a thousand and
people love it i don't know what it is
right like what's better than a one of
one a one of 10k
yeah
yeah exactly okay this is this is
impossible oh the pudgies yup i'm
locking b in right now you're looking b
and c now
i think it's gonna have to be a because
it looks like it's got like the
pineapple's gonna be a rare trait so i'm
going a oh shoot that's a good point
ah yes sir yes sir
400 400k dude let's go that's definitely
a rare yeah it's like the dude for five
thousand dollars 100 people with a pudgy
due rag right i haven't seen the
pineapple one very good showing your
skills here listen
pays to waste your entire life on
twitter oh my which sold for the most
amount of money uh i'm i'm gonna go with
because that's the only one i've seen
out of those two but a oh man but a does
look like it could have been like an
establishment
it could have been like an establishment
i'm gonna go a cause i would rather have
a yes i'm gonna stick with b but i like
you i like your answer because okay i'm
just gonna say this either a sold for a
lot of money it was a one-of-one rare
thing or you just like blew me out of
the water
of course of course and you're sold for
200 000 well mine sold for a hundred
dollars
yes
you can never go wrong with the
collection dude
final round here we go guess the price
of the nft to the closest amount okay
this is what we tried to do initially
yeah yeah this is this is where you
can't you can't fake this okay you can't
fake this knowledge man yeah doge kitty
kitties
all right i'm gonna go ahead i'm gonna
we have to write that this down yeah
yeah that makes sense that makes sense i
gotta pay a pen
get something i got pen and paper right
here
okay
i'm gonna go ahead uh man okay
50k i went going i went 12k
oh man
wait sold for 2e 375 dollars when was
this
that means i have no idea
i mean that means eth was worth 170 at
the time
oh it was worth it yeah right so this is
so this must have just been held for
i don't know a year two years maybe if
you're looking at last sale so but if
we're going i guess we gotta go on price
of the time yeah we gotta go a price at
the time because that's what the person
felt like they were paying but that
means you win and you're up two which
puts me my back against the wall here
bad [ __ ] and i need to i need to tie it
up here
i almost minted the crypto dad but then
i realized doing anything on ethereum is
like pouring paint then in your eyes so
i decided not to
[Laughter]
minting especially so we are guessing at
the time when do you remember when this
was this isn't too long ago a couple
months couple probably like three
two and a half three months ago peak
hype i would say i'm gonna tell you this
right now leon that's a critical mistake
you just made i just sucked you for all
the information yeah
i can't believe you fell for that my
nemesis listen i am a benevolent and a
loving crypto king all right i will
i will i will spread some i will spread
some some bread out for the ducks i'm
gonna go this
okay
i got 20k i got 50k which i think might
be aggressive but that's very aggressive
160.
yes sir i'm getting i'm getting
absolutely crushed right now dude
what bug 16 yeah that's definitely one
of their top 10 rares in there you know
what i'm realizing i should have started
at a more manageable opponent here all
right you know
i didn't realize how much you uh you you
were how much you were on crypto twitter
here i don't have a lot of i don't have
a lot of friends in real life right i
just spent my days on my cell phone
looking at jpegs yeah it said post
pandemic syndrome just side note who
would have thought that so many people
if you just pay people to look at jpegs
they will do it yeah oh yeah absolutely
or or don't you could actually take
their money and they'll still look at it
kill frog 3376 all right let's look
let's see what this is i'm gonna go
ahead and say
all right i'm not gonna
i may be
spreading disinformation here but i'm
gonna say this is an 100k
item you're i feel like you're close so
again this is a generative one obviously
10k pfp uh mint
dracula is typically a rare trait so i
would put him in like the top 20 to 40
out of 10k
so i think hundreds not too crazy i'm
going to say i'm going to say 120k i'm
gonna prices write you a little bit
but you still have the whole you have
the whole window under 100 so it could
be i'm not sure how popular this actual
collection is so that could be my my bad
i think you're gonna go way off here but
oh
man that was close oh that's close baby
wow
damn dude i was actually about to change
my answer at the end there and be like
i'm changing going like a hundred
dollars and thank god i didn't no no you
nailed it so man that was that was
without a doubt the closest one we'll
have today off by a couple thousand
direction is that wait i i think that
might be the game ball game i'm down one
oh bonus round
thank you harry thank you can we get
some bonus round music please huh so
this is not familiar with the meme or
wherever this is from it looks like a
pepe chad it looks rare it does look
rare i don't think it's part of a
collection though see that
before it told us like if it was it had
like a number this is just uh this is
hard mode this is what you get for going
to the bonus round yeah this is all
the marbles on the line oh man that
thing looks so rare i feel like i should
know this collection too but everything
is just 24 pixels all right um i know
what i'm doing
i know what i'm doing all right
i'm i'm bumping it up
whoa okay 150 for me 110.
okay let's go let's see what it is sold
for eight thousand six hundred sixty six
dollars
yes the king of crypto is here
oh my god this
this feels so rigged dude wow